au canada près de 60 % de la nourriture
qui est produite au pays et jeté en
temps de crise sanitaire on limite nos
déplacements au supermarché on fait de
grosse épicerie et il peut être facile
de perdre des aliments économiquement
c'est aussi un temps difficiles alors
avant de jeter si on tentait de
récupérer nos aliments pour diminuer le
gaspillage alimentaire à la maison plus
je cuisinais avec rien dit mais
j'apprenais à revaloriser des chaluts
mentaires que j'avais du succès florence
la syrie est devenue par la force des
choses une experte dans la lutte au
gaspillage alimentaire des fois elle est
jeune dit mais c'est dans bay bon
qu'est-ce qu'ils étaient cuisinés puis
je leur disais bon c'est la même chose
qu'il ya trois ans j'ai ouï c'est juste
que j'ai complètement changé l'apparence
en bonifiant mon repas donc je leur
donnais toujours un deuxième puis une
troisième vie puis j'apprenais à areva
le risque était un déchets alimentaires
qui on aurait ajouté
c'est en développant sa créativité alors
qu'elle était cantinière sur les
plateaux de tournage qu'elle a trouvé
des façons de ne plus gaspiller de
nourriture moi j'étais confiant sur les
plateaux de tournage pendant 17 ans puis
d'une année à l'autre les prix la
nourriture a augmenté mais les
conditions de travail c'est de plus en
plus difficile et les budgets aussi
devenu de plus en plus minime donc
j'avais pas le choix de trouver des
solutions pour être fier de mon travail
chez vous vous demandez cotisé avec les
fonds fac traîne en garde manger deux
cantinières florence léa est devenu
conférencière au triste et à la
développer le chic frigo son fric
un blog où elle se consacre à
l'éducation populaire via ses réseaux
sociaux depuis le début de la pandémie
les questions sur son site ont explosé
selon lui qui m'a écrit un seul instant
y rendre pour me dire qu'elle avait
acheté une boucle drogba nantes m'a
demandé tu es d et es cuisineries 8
différente de celle pour pas en
gaspiller une seule
chaque jour au canada on gaspille plus
de 550 milles banane mais aussi plus de
2 millions de pommes de terre
plus d'un million de pommes de tomates
si on apprenne à mieux conserver les
aliments
nadia ce que j'alimente à réduire et
probablement de 50% ça avoir fait autre
chose que mieux comprendre comme un
aliment besoin d'être conservé
hydratation température emballages
nettoyage sont des notions à retenir
pour la conservation la meilleure façon
pour conserver le fenouil c'est de le
maintenir hydrater on voit ici que
commence à se déshydrater en pieds
attachés donc s'arrêter de le mettre
dans un petit bol d'eau tout cm d'eau
couper la partie supérieure alors le
concombre devant l'achat dans un étalage
qui n'est pas réfrigérée premier truc
pour réfrigérer égale comtois deuxième
truc
j'enlève l'emballage seulement au frigo
dans son emballage souvent les
extrémités vont faire des blessures au
froid la condensation va abîmer le
concombre il devient plus mou très
simplement le mettre dans un petit bocal
dos et il va rester croquants beaucoup
plus longtemps
la fameuse leti mélanger leur première
chose mosquée je fais c'est que je
change l'emballage j'aurais pu
simplement prendre le contenu et jérémy
dans un grand contenant pour qu'elle
soit respect et je l'aurai déposé dans
le fond de mon contenant un linge propre
qui valait absorber les surplus
d'humidité
si vous n'avez pas de compte en ce que
vous pouvez faire c'est simplement
déposer un linge absorbant par contre
moi ce que je fais c'est que je renverse
pour que l'immunité puisse tomber dans
le linge absorbant donc j'ai une petite
microgestion j'enlève est comme ça moi
je suis capable de garder ma les teams
et cela jusqu'à 14 jours
florence l'aiea propose trois façons de
tirer profit d'un déchets alimentaires
c'est partie d'aliments comestibles que
l'on jette soit infuse et assaisonner et
transformé
ça peut être de faire infuser un
bouillon un jus m les épluchures
d'oignons par exemple dans mon lit va
faire un beau rit jaune et il va goûter
un peu l'oignon donc non j'ai pas mangé
la peau d'oignons mais par contre je
vais bonifier mon riz les épluchures de
patates douces on pourrait les accumuler
avec d'autres revues alimentaire pour
faire un bouillon sinon moi ce que
j'aime bien faire lorsqu'elles ne sont
pas tacher le noir je les enrobe d'huile
je les assaisonne j'ai les mains au four
et je les transforme en petit chai pour
manger à l'apéro alors ici je me suis
permis de fouiller dans le frigo et ce
qui a attiré mon attention c'est une
foule de petits restent en restant de
patates douces déjà grillé sera
transformée et servira de base pour
faire des canapés
si j'avais eu droit qu'à moi donc je
prends une tartinade se répète de
l'humus peu importe là quelque chose qui
me les pieds de reculer attiré mon
attention je m'en servir pour ajouter
une petite touche de creux cas et de
décoration pourquoi pas comme ça
les patates douces peuvent être aussi
transformé en un potage ou encore ajouté
dans un mélange de pâte à crêpes
on aurait pu le faire avec des rasets
pinard et des restes de chou frisé
certains m'ont même utiliser les fans un
bout de concombres oublier que tous ces
êtres sauver quelqu'un n'aurait pas
envie de le manger mais rap et ça me
donne envie de les mettre dans mon c est
ce qu on le pressent comme ça l'on va
sortir et vous pourriez garder l'eau
pour faire un petit show tort de
concombres même dans un cocktail voyez
c'est une recette qui m'a pas pris
beaucoup de temps aux femmes et qui m'a
permis de liquider plusieurs aliments
qui était en fin de vie font diogo et un
pli tri citron qui était vraiment plus
très beau donc schaller tirer le maximum
de ces aliments c'est un canevas de
recettes donc si la semaine prochaine
nous dresse une betterave un peu molle
vous pouvez faire un baiser qui la
semaine d'après un karotz ziki et vous
voyez cédait toujours rebondir ce la
structure de la recette mais de la
personnaliser en fonction de ce qu'on a
dans le frigo dans le garde-manger et
dans le congélateur
personne n'est à l'abri de l'insécurité
alimentaire surtout en période d que
vides
le fait d'apprendre à autre
lisez les aliments nous permet d'être
beaucoup plus créatif à la fois en
cuisine mais aussi sur les hautes
sphères de notre vie mais je crois qu'en
ce moment les gens peut-être un petit
peu plus de temps à la maison
donc c'est le moment de s'attarder à un
item de devenir bon de développer cette
confiance et de l'essayer d'un aliment
alimente son besoin d'économies se
transforme aussi en un geste pour la
planète c'est pas juste une matière
qu'on gaspille c'est des ressources tic
c'est complexe un gaspillage alimentaire
et je crois qu'on n'ait plus ces moyens
là pour moi c'est juste un mode de vie
clame minutes vont comprendre quel point
c'est fabuleux et qu'on mange mieux que
jamais mais c'est difficile de revenir
en arrière
[Musique]